welcome to this video ja ja ja door from
the Netherlands and we get a king's
gambit yeah the Kings gambit always fun
come on let's take it I come on and play
I don't know it but let's play g5 it
tends to lead to to really end really am
entertaining games is this the slide
where white goes for quick g3 the
quarter quarter caught whatever
variation I don't know yeah this stuff
yeah okay I'm going to take it whatever
then aged six I guess what the weird
opening okay so what is really
concentrating is forces on f7 but I have
to support the same you see threatening
any direct sacrifice maybe maybe he is
hmm 96-95 TX takes on h8 Queen h5 at the
end business like that might work it
might yeah maybe I should play Knight f6
first to avoid stuff like that I come on
let's do that Wow is this opening is
really crazy 94 94 that looks lit looks
interesting actually or maybe do this
first and wait if he plays Queen d2 or
anything then I g4 really gets more
attractive I also wonder if maybe Knight
takes e4 can be an idea this zero
sacrifice probably not
yeah II five can be can be a problem
that's clear maybe I should should
really play this more and if possible
take this thing yeah what now Bishop e6
runs into a fork so not bad we need 795
not not good can I go nitey seven
somehow trying to prepare long castles
or should I castle short just just like
that come on maybe this is really not a
big deal
one minute down here how do I get
counter play him some some sort of play
on my own beep on somehow a 6b five I
don't know son
yeah the night on g4 is really annoying
for why did sir it keeps his
coordination somewhat disturbed
b5 I mean I might be able to exchange
the bishop on see Freud if the c-4
bishop is traded on against the night
for example I think I already should be
in in a really good shape ok but now I
can take and take on d4 potentially yeah
okay I need to take any way now taking
on deform blunders away the h6 pawn and
he s this diagonal open ok maybe night e
7 going over here three notches exam
maybe this lending some support and also
may be preparing bishop e6 yeah ok this
was was maybe an interesting move Bishop
is six to trade him
d 5v5 looks wrong but if it takes I have
take stakes I have Queenie eight maybe
okay well how do i check with the night
yeah I guess with the night and queen
have six necks are now this this this
must be okay for me really would be did
this this would be strange and it would
be really good for wide I mean of course
he this is just a merc you still a murky
position but objectively speaking black
must be excellent here
if I return the exchange does this
simplify matters on like g4s civil and f
ing form
junk I can also just double him maybe
just
trying to time morning go from them and
yeah Queen trade
yeah it's still it is still murky don't
really see a very clear-cut win if there
is any I mean maybe there isn't rupee
eight blunders stuff so better not can
give the check on edge seven okay okay
with one room traded time I'm confident
now yeah I get the bishop to d6 which
makes the pone make the pawns run
white resigns yeah this is notoriously
mukhiya whatever you do it still it's
this somewhat strange yeah I always
wanted to Castle long in this position
it feels like the the safeway but maybe
this is entirely wrong and I can really
just cancel short this is what I did
ultimately there was a game larger short
with wide against Luke McShane in one of
the London chess classic swell McShane
also canceled law CASL short it was
pretty similar the position and he
really had no problem whatsoever yeah
maybe this is really the way to play it
stakes it went here oh wow now here oh
that's nice the computer show us an
excellent move here um yeah white white
play and and win here after 97 which was
a blunder here look f6 this is nice out
intending Luke age six breaking through
and if I take it's very clearly a maid
coming very nice this would have been a
great way for him to win the game but
okay you went here this should be six
and now again we have six wins but okay
went here yeah now the computer is
giving me an advantage yeah he had
spoiled those those chances the position
however is still not not easy ya hear
the comp gives g-form hmm now I think
this this was also okay really no idea
this should be good for me but it is
still not easy to play and I'm
absolutely unsure if he maybe had
something
yeah up to now the comp is not objecting
very much to my moves NTM winning yeah
he probably had those chances with rook
f6 when I when I allowed that when i
blundered to allow those moves but yeah
and then blitz just not so easy to see
yeah I hope you enjoyed this crazy game
the King's gambit is always fun thanks
for watching